i mean i know this has only been a
little while have you guys started
wedding planning yet yeah we have
actually started wedding planning um
cole is not invited but um it's gonna be
great
there's a spin-off of um
to all the boys i i've loved before i'm
sure you are aware are you interested in
uh doing a cameo or no i you know i
haven't had any conversations hey
how's uh the mars boyfriend
long distance dating sucks how long have
you guys been together eight years eight
years how did you manage that he checks
all the boxes oh you mean literally
strong jaw mental fortitude six-pack
what do you think uh people are gonna
appreciate about a good space rom-com i
think people will appreciate watching
like
two people stuck in a room together i
because it's because there's a line in
the movie where it's like it's like what
happens when two people are stuck in a
room together it
it's either uh more humans or less
humans and i think that that concept is
so fun and i think people will genuinely
like enjoy watching kind of that banter
of the two of us just like
trapped
i i think it's honestly it's a feel-good
movie i think it's it's not too heavy um
it's not it's not something that's gonna
emotionally wear on you i think after
after everything that we've all been
through in the last three years i i
think just having a nice easy to digest
piece of of cinema is going to be really
sweet and really nice and hopeful and
it's it's it's just an easy and fun
watch and and
you know when i i was saying when it
first came across my table
it reminds me a lot of those
those just feel good movies that the
industry was making back in like early
2000s it's just it's it's a it's a nice
thing to watch it's very it's
it's easy to digest you can watch with
the whole family i think that's i think
that's kind of what i would want as an
audience member right now after all this
and i think what what families will want
too yeah yeah a meet cute version of
being locked in a room together versus
yeah yeah
which was making sense
order you or throw you out of the house
i don't know yeah a lot of you built
such a a loyal audience with all the
boys i've loved before what do you think
that audience is going to think about
this i hope that they love it um i think
my my audience is very very loving and
my my my fans simply love love and for
some reason they love watching me fall
in love and
it's to me
in terms of my career i really do want
the projects that i
am a part of to
have the audience leaving feeling
hopeful and uplifting and believe in
love so i hope that they love it if they
don't love it it's cole's fault it's not
mine and i think it'll be great
call a response how do you feel about
that
um nothing she said was was a lie uh if
they don't love it it's probably mine no
you know what i told cole i told you i
was like hey cool like just so you know
like my fans are really really nice
and kind and loving uh yeah
it's gonna be great so in the spirit of
the film and sophie's list what are
three items that you guys would have on
your checklist uh for a life partner
oh
i mean first off let me preface this by
saying i think if you have a checklist
for a life partner you're probably
starting off on the wrong yes here yes
let me just put that out there a lot of
people have them though you've got oh no
i would say i would say
um i personally
someone who's funny
um i
someone who's funny um
someone who
um is kind and someone who
my dad likes yeah i mean i think that's
important
i think someone
for me i think someone that your dad
likes
um
yeah it's important yeah very important
to you for sure that's cool
um no i i i think foodie i think humor
um
uh experimentation for sure i think
the ability to explore an adventure is
is really big for me like big
experimental eater that sort of stuff is
really important and someone loves to
travel lana you're uh you recently
announced your engagement how many of
those qualities does your partner have
oh he had i mean he has all of them he
he did ask my dad for my hand in
marriage which was very important to me
i didn't tell him to do that so the fact
that he did do that was really really
amazing um i think he's the funniest
person ever i
i am
oftentimes find him more funny than
what's on television so i'll just watch
him like i love watching him exist i
love watching him live live like he's so
hilarious
amazing um he has it all and i love him
very very much and i'm very excited
kudos to him for for for going out to
dad
yeah
laws is a is serious business man that
can be very scary i was very nervous
about that when i when i got engaged oh
yeah no he was he was he was that's not
to say he he was very afraid but he did
it anyways which i think is brave i mean
i know this has only been a little while
have you guys started wedding planning
yet that's also a very intense period of
life yeah we have actually started
wedding planning um cole is not invited
but um it's going to be great
are you uninvited yourself
well on paper i'm uninvited but
realistically i'm the guy way in the
back and like a wide-brimmed black hat
standing by the tree everyone's going
like who's that mysterious
no but we have started wedding planning
it's uh it hasn't been stressful for me
i
well
because the the film is about you people
going to mars and this is a thing that
humans are beginning to explore right
now yeah if given the opportunity would
either one of you hop on one of these
planes right now and float up into the
atmosphere or
no thanks let everybody else try it
first and then let's see how it goes my
go-to answer is
the people that need to be up there
should go first there's no reason lana
needs to be up in space i would be
providing absolutely nothing um i think
send the scientists up there first i'll
come
you know when it's commercial
i mean i agree i cannot think of any
legitimate reason you need to view the
space but i guarantee you that if i am
allowed on any of these vessels i'm
gonna make it a riot
ever since i was a kid i've dreamt of
going to mars
you can keep my dream alive come with me
you cannot under any circumstances leave
my room okay
this is gonna suck isn't it only for 35
days i'm going to bring a fiddle i don't
even play the fiddle but i'm going to
play i'm going to the worst is you
learning how to play i'm going to play
the worst fiddle in space yeah yeah
on the ship so you can learn to play the
fiddle
so lana there's there's a spin-off of um
to all the boys i i've loved before i'm
sure you are aware are you interested in
uh doing a cameo or are you gonna pop up
in that do you have you had any
conversations
no i you know i haven't had any
conversations about that however i think
that i i'm very excited for anna
cathcart who plays kitty this is kind of
it's kind of her turn now to kind of um
fall in love and have new experiences so
i'm very excited for her and i think
she's very ready and capable to do so
well hopefully you can lock down a
an invite to the wedding before the end
of today
i keep trying after every interview she
i get farther and farther he gets
further further away
bring the fiddle and you can fiddle as
she's going down i'll play the fiddle at
your wedding
[Music]
you